[Music]
the implementation of the weapon is
embarrassing
it's basically a handoff dude i got
four headshots with this thing are we
playing overwatch right now jesus
the guy that i had sheltered through my
friend i did 285
damage what like should that even be
allowed
and he's gonna be nervous i mean it has
to be nerfed back in 2015
valve released an update for cs go that
introduced replay kill cams
christmas sweaters for chickens and the
most
busted game breaking gun of all time
they called it the r8 we
called it the revolvo
you got one shot somebody with a [ __ ]
pistol
why is that allowed
to go
like oh [ __ ]
oh my god oh
oh jesus for 48 hours
cs go became a broken mess just
absolutely mayhem and to this day
people still wonder what the [ __ ] was
val
thinking
[Music]
december 8th 2015 a date which will
live on in infamy the patch notes called
for
in-game gifting holiday cheer community
stickers
service medals pretty standard stuff
valve
reduced pistol accuracy and increased
bullet spread for ars
essentially nerfing everything that
wasn't a sniper and then
buried within was the unassuming and
inconspicuous
r8 according to the patch notes it
occupied the desert eagle
loadout slot but the notes didn't say
anything else in the loadout menu it was
described as having a
highly accurate and powerful round at
the expense of a lengthy trigger pull
me and some friends were talking like a
few weeks ago actually and we
said like wouldn't it be hilarious if
they changed the deagle for a revolver
there was like oh yeah dude that thief
is sick
now while most players were adjusting to
the new recoil patterns of the ak and
the m4
others like anomaly were in for a treat
oh yeah one shots in the stomach yeah
this is going to be so insanely [ __ ]
overpowered
the guy that i headshotted through my
friend i did 285 damage
what love this is like
legit [ __ ] sniper it had a better
range
than the aching the hitbox of a shotgun
and bullet penetration not seen since
[Music]
goldeneye
but worst of all in addition to its
versatility
valve thought it would be a good idea to
give the r8 a pistol
a secondary the same base damage
as an op and the game's most prominent
streamers and pros
like freakazoid were pissed you got one
shot somebody
with a [ __ ] pistol why is that
allowed
that's the stupidest thing and then look
this [ __ ] up gets sniper bro i literally
just bought an off
in an accurate off for 850 dollars i
could one shot people
and then i have a sniper for a left
click
look at that recoil pattern all right so
what you're going to want to do to
control this recoil
you're going to really want to focus in
on [ __ ] holding mouse 1.
jesus finally as though the entire
update was just an elaborate troll
the revolvo had the distinct honor of
being usable
even when defusing the bomb no matter
how you looked at it the r8
was a class apart it was without a doubt
the most busted gun in cs go history
nothing even comes close
[Music]
[Music]
now putting aside the fun that streamers
like summit were having with this
nonsense
it was a pretty big deal you see since
cs go's humble origins
the ak and m4 have always been the go-to
guns
and while other rifles have had their
time in the sun such as in the infamous
og and krieg metas
the ak and m4 have long been the
immovable staples of the game but now
the meta was a handgun and nothing made
sense anymore
everyone was using it and every match
just devolved into a 5 on 5
western shootout saves no longer served
a purpose
and an eco round may as well have been a
full buy
since 850 bucks got you the best gun in
the game
one small update and valve had
essentially nuked
csgo's entire economy do we need to save
uh yeah let's let's just for the hell of
it let's just buy money off
are we using real weapons or just uh the
good one this is the real weapon
i'm just using the real weapon
now all you got to do you can buy every
round though so you just gotta
fall over every round bro
of course pro players never got the
chance to test out the r8 on the main
stage
esl season 2 was scheduled that weekend
and event organizers were under
considerable pressure to address
the most recent update between all of
the bad press and the outcry from
players both casual
and professional seeing the r8 on a pro
stage would have been devastating esl
was quick to announce that they would
not be playing with the new patch so as
to maintain the competitive spirit of
the event
given the amount of money and prestige
on the line
and while they never specifically
mentioned the r8 as being the culprit
it's safe to say that it probably had
something to do with it
[Music]
oh [ __ ] the revolver was
i mean is by far too op and he's going
to be nerfed and
it has to be nerfed and then all of a
sudden it was over
as quickly as it had begun not even 48
hours later
and big surprise the revolvo was nerfed
into obscurity valve put out a press
release
stating while it typically takes more
time to generate enough data to drive an
update
in this case it's clear that we got the
damage wrong and can
respond immediately the nerfs included
increasing the trigger pull time from
0.33 to 0.4 seconds
while reducing the base damage from 115
to 85 that meant that the r8 now needed
an
extra shot to get the job done what was
originally intended to be an exciting
new weapon that would shake up the meta
and encourage new strategies
wound up being a slow unwieldy
ineffective
meme cannon that would soon be forgotten
from
pocket op to paperweight valve's
experiment was a colossal
failure a poster child for testing
patches
before they launch these days no one in
their right mind is going to swap
a deagle for a revolver in competitive
play
so dignitas have a great opportunity to
catch up
and jw has brought something disgusting
then
we say it's disgusting it's actually
just it's just a terrible weapon
it's just not even good or is it
maybe he's been practicing hard maybe he
knows the secrets hey we need jwcam
because i
i don't care what else happened no no oh
no
but sometimes in the interest of comedy
the r8
still has its place in the cs universe
if only there was a meme slot for the
likes of
the dualies and revolvos
at the end of the day the revolvo fiasco
shows us just how fragile and precious
csgo really is
all it takes is a few lines of
well-intentioned code and the entire
program begins to unravel
at least for a couple of days if only
there was a meme slot for dualies and
revolvos
yo the dualies are sick don't talk [ __ ]
about the dualies
the dualies are lit the dooley's double
flash starting round is my go-to
meme loadout two flashes and dualies in
the first round
that's that good [ __ ] oh that's not good
[ __ ] like there is like this secret cult
of like r8 users of which i am not a
part by the way just want to be very
clear
who like actually do use the gun over
the deagle because the d
it's only uh worse than the eagle if you
have a really good aim and most pro
players have really good aim so that's
why they all take the vehicle because if
you're if you're an aimbot like the
deagle is just a godzilla weapon it's
just unbelievably
good but if your aim is not great like
you're like a normal human being who
doesn't have very good aim the r8 is
like theoretically better
they called it the r8 we called it
the revolvo my voice cracked so
they